hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to blank dream now we
got to the first jump-scare of the game
which was actually pretty cool I mean if
I hadn't thought about it I might have
been caught by that but I'm very smart
and also I go oh ooh I don't like this
the teddy bear stairs with round eyes
cute not not my first impression in a
dark room of snare Oh corridors those
narrow corridors you're gonna get okay
wookie the fireplace quietly lights up
the room does it is this what this is
it's a room sure carefully remove the
lantern gotta pull some amnesia
shooty sure heard the fireplace go out
the room was swallowed by darkness oh
boy
good thing I gotta learn oh I'm already
using it I guess well that's good it's
too dark to see inside oh boy
oh hi what are you gonna do to me what
are you gonna do to me why aren't you
commentating on all the blood on the
walls that seems to be a problem mer
that's a handprint oh boy
I mean Oh like you this No Oh should I
go see the teddy bear just four years
ago hello the teddy bear stairs and
round eyes cute gun not what I would
suspect to say in such a situation okay
I guess I'm just supposed to find the
exit but I already knew where the eggs
it was okay all right cool well now all
there was to that was there nothing more
to add there had to be like something
else
let me no likey this this is supposed to
be a field of green and dreams turns
into a field of bullshitting nightmares
a dead tree choppy choppy that bastard
ex huh
thank you I needed that oh god I got
firewood ah look [ __ ] you god damn it
piece of [ __ ] God good take all your
bird baths and Ram your dog freaking box
yeah
hello again cute okay so I gotta go
she's in the fireplace ah ah okay
alright okay how about a little bit of
this put a little bit odd fire it in
there nope not that that one no maybe
maybe it was a bad idea to come back in
here I didn't know what I needed
I didn't who knows doing let me god damn
it don't do that to me I was choked show
is that a good sound rubout sound is I
one of them batteries and I don't know
I'm going to shave
okie dokie then I'll just go somewhere
else
large tree well I probably should have
used the axon that that's what's been a
good idea but no I didn't do what I need
to do
alright so do I need to go get another
decorative axe and then maybe Oh
my axe broke so I can't do that maybe I
used it on the wrong thing oh hi hello
who's mumbly moon Lee in the darkness Oh
what men wait well I've been trying that
forever it didn't go through
oh okay that's what I thought I needed
to do but it didn't do it when I wanted
it why did right was it different then
okay that's okay never mind anyway
continuing on that's a clock should've I
was a big dumb dummy dumb dumb dumb dumb
the marini okay so now oh no it faded
into ashes the tree was burnt down to
ashes that's exactly what I said okay so
now what are you where am I going to now
what am i that's not a pleasant sound
ome roar oh goody goody gumdrops mirror
shows mashiro's reflection look deep
into it and then find a way to finish
yourself off apparently because this
can't get any darker six months ago I've
been here for six months
Oh unless isn't exactly when I was going
to do it Oh thinking back it was a
boring life I wouldn't say it was
entirely devoid of enjoyment but if you
asked whether I'd live the same life
again I'd absolutely refuse without a
doubt in the fact if I had to say I've
come to hate it all I wish my life had
never even existed
more or less again wishy-washy
mirror-like
I might as well just test that rumor
there like a lake in a desolate Park
about 20 minute train ride from home
there was an old rumor about it it was
sad hey nice weather huh great rumor
great rumor great rumor hello friend I'm
talking to you no one else here is there
who would you be
oh just a passing high-school student
but I noticed you staring at the leg
with that hollow look there's always a
chance so I thought I should call out to
you that's unnecessary no I'm not gonna
jump it good that's good to hear but
there are strange rumors about me
roulette
stuff like it being a gate between now
our world in the afterlife myself had to
see it being true to its name reflecting
the parks natural scenery like a mirror
the music's real goodness came by the
way you're probably thinking this guy
sure talks a lot huh you see I'm not
gonna I'm going on talking to you to
make sure you don't get any ideas
I said I'm not jumping in well that's
good
oh I should mention I'm a yacht oh he
know Hara I came to paint the park today
I'm not just trying to flirt
but is it working why tell me your name
are you flirting are you flirting
no this isn't huniepop I just said I'm
not introductions are a first step to
breaking down barriers so what's your
name I'm not telling you cuz I'm a jerk
yeah that's what I figured
okey-dokey then so you actually did come
to paint you're a spiteful one huh did
you think I was carrying this clunky
easel for just for show not really oh
well if you're not here for suicide you
should stick around for a bit
I get absent-minded when I'm painting
but still it's lonely when no one's
around he's flirting that's such
flirting any items which Massaro has in
the present she does not have in the
past and thus cannot use well that's
that's a handy dandy feature should I
just go for a running sprint off the end
of the dock I have a bit of a connection
to Mirror Lake so my feet just carried
me here that's good to know
okay so am I supposed to just you know
hunker down for a bit and just flibbidee
flu I have a knife that's the thing I
thought I said I wouldn't have that what
about the pure I Otto is focused on his
painting and isn't looking at mashiro
well not just yet let's just determine
whether this is actually the correct
course of action first zero cubes okay
so I don't think we're back you know all
righty then how about I use a knife on
you okay no all right okay goodbye
farewell cruel horrible it's sure it'll
surely be painful Oh God aah
oh that's so bad well there we go
Thank You Otto your pep talk made me
throw myself in the lake Wow oh this is
so dark so dark it's so dark
um Ashera came to again standing before
the mirror though she still felt lake
water in her nose her clothes were not
even slightly wet yes I met a yato in
Mirror Lake that day
I'm starting to remember a little more
about myself oh I guess all things
considered in the previous memory
obviously she didn't shove the knife in
her throat then in there she's just
doing these to recover the memories and
break the mirrors so it's connected but
at the same time not entirely just as
mashiro regained a piece of her memory
she felt as if she'd lost something
important
hey this is all gonna be really
meaningful very soon here sure got a
bronze key hooray
one's the best of all Olympic medals and
colors and medals that's I got the [ __ ]
wish use me what was that part anymore I
am have I am trying to have a good time
and you throw that at me what was that
laughs Thank You GU thinking okay that's
not good why is that there why
we 200 I get it
oh oh okay oh I see oh I see so closely
this good game this is good this is good
game I like this game it's good I want
ten more of this game iron bars just out
of the ground it seems impossible to
climb over them I know they're so high
and the risk for impalement is equally
also as high yeah what can I do
oh you need to stop that now you need to
stop that why don't I have any
commentary about the bloody handprint
god this game is jump scary Oh Mashiro
over here come on I don't even know if
you're real I have a funny feeling that
your home look it's amazing another
person it's rare remember just a wee
creep stay oh a creep Oh forgive me but
why so harsh looking at you makes them
something nagging me
I couldn't understand why so I'd change
a pace here
okay probably not acquainted or anything
right
hey my name is ryutarou probably that's
the name in the suit so not like I
remembered it myself so it feels
strangely unreal
I'm Mashiro right nice to meet you
I guess I was wandering the strange
world for a bit poring finding you zoom
here
what's with it really feels like some
other dimension this is a world where
souls with a wish end up can you
remember your wish RIA taro wish I
wonder Oh like wonder wow what wonderful
intensely oh how I wish I could remember
my wish anyway you can't remember
anything exact huh seems that way like a
fog over all my memories oh yeah I was
like that at first
Mashiro isn't special I guess when I was
at first I haven't really been counting
so all I can say is really a while ago
I think it's been several years maybe so
you died years ago probably long enough
ago that I've forgotten used to this
place and having no memory but the only
time I got any sort of memory back was
the time I found a mirror with my
reflection I've seen other mirrors
around this world but they showed other
people or nothing at all the mirrors are
deep in the realms huh
seriously sure you've been really
proactive or I'm not looking have you
keep it up and find more mirrors could
you try to look for our mirrors too I
don't think it's a coincidence that you
seem different from other souls mashiro
just while you're at it if you have time
if you don't forget about me or anything
I mean I'll be over here I'm not passing
for us or anything but I just really if
you don't forget about little ol me it's
totally fine whatever yeah
alright so anyway that's enough for this
part thank you everybody so much for
watching I am thoroughly enjoying this
one this is really good it's been a
while since I played an RPG horror game
that was this good so I'm very eager to
keep playing with it so thank you
everybody again and as always I will see
you
and the next video yes
take the damn don't listen if you don't
know then do